you see this drake
[ __ ]
um
where do you want to start okay well
we've never talked about um his [ __ ]
uh
his
space steak yeah
steak.com right yeah that's what it is
yeah i don't know we probably don't have
to promote the url the uh steak.com yeah
codyco
promo code oh really i'm kidding wow
wow let's see if that works
no i'm kidding are you joking dude
i am joking that's a joke i've never
used steak before i'm not being paid to
promote them but drake is apparently
definitely
no it's it's uh someone told me isn't it
like public news or no drake and crypto
betting site stake officially announced
partnership yeah yeah but someone told
me how much he's getting paid for it
how do they know
because he also got paid by stake to do
something oh
and uh
i'm not like i barely know this guy just
um he told me this at a party and it was
like something [ __ ] crazy like eight
million dollars a month
or something ins where i was just
literally like what well
okay i get it wow
is that are we just like starting a
rumor now
what do you mean you're just making up a
number that drake's making everyone i
mean it was something like that yeah
yeah no it was some crazy amount of
money no but why don't we just change it
to like okay it was uh yeah
57 million dollars a month
57 million dollars a month yeah
a minute
we need to give like all the
all the instagram accounts something to
clip yeah
57 million a month drake is making 57
million dollars a minute that's a
mistake a minute that is crazy so total
add up what is that
oh god it's like a hundred and
two thousand billion a month yeah
wow to promote steak yep
i mean nuts
yeah you know just th this is the
funniest part about nfts and all that
it's just like the people i said this on
the trail podcast
the people who yeah look at this drake
has wagered over a billion on stake
since joining in december how does that
even make sense
well because first of all it's not his
money yeah he's getting bankrolled he's
getting bankrolled
secondly it's great that everyone who's
in crypto you know that's like
advertising all that is just already way
ahead of everyone else financially yeah
that's [ __ ] awesome that um
they're being given more wealth yeah
this is really cool yeah and it's just
monopoly money to them too yeah
like like 10 million i would have been
like holy [ __ ] if that's at 10 million
yeah a billion that's a 10 million
dollars that would have been like whole
since december yeah you've wagered 10
you've bet 10 million dollars on
gambling that's [ __ ] insane yeah
it's a billion that's the real number
what that's that's a hundred millions
right
that's a hundred no that's a thousand
million thousand millions sorry oh yeah
i'm dumb yeah a thousand a hundred
million
yeah yeah
yeah i was just testing you
just making sure duke degree still works
hey duke one yesterday did they let's go
[ __ ] belt
dude oh with the gloves
wow
[Laughter]
no
that hurt dude
yeah drake doesn't need any more money
though you know it's like he's just
destroying people's lives with crypto
gambling now it's it's he's destroying
them for what you're already [ __ ] you
already have 500 million dollars or
something absolutely a thousand million
why do you need more
take it all [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him yeah yeah just yeah wait yeah
wager a billion dollars yeah it's so
cool that
he gets to him you know
anyone else we don't even got to name
them you know the people with their big
nft scams and crypto scams it's [ __ ]
dope these people rinse their fans and
then get to go perform in like live
event spaces and they got people front
row that are like you [ __ ]
dug into my wallet and took money from
me yeah when i bought this ticket and
when i invested in your
you know when i used your code to bet my
life savings
on virtual roulette that is a thousand
percent rigged against me
i love you drake yeah it's [ __ ] dope
that you have fans like that exactly
that are just like drain me yeah dream
me
train me drake
better yet let me drain you dog yeah
empty my bank train you for draining me
[Music]
imagine going to work
to fuel drake you know what i'm saying
yeah like yeah
you're like i'm going to go clock in
today and when my direct deposit hits
i'm going to make sure drake gets every
is there actually any way we could
do a direct deposit to his bank account
yeah
yeah or something or if there's maybe a
way we could just convert it to crypto
right away and it could just go to his
stake account
because i want to get him i want to get
him to 10 billy
wagered that's my goal that's why i work
because i want to see that 10 billion
number
bro
when you get [ __ ] you get your like
w-2 like for your employment form and
then they ask for your direct deposit
information and you're writing aubrey
graham
are you
hi
just guessing
no what's this place called the embassy
yeah it's like the toronto white house i
don't know yeah i'm just guessing what's
a canadian street
oh i mean i know one but i'm saying not
in toronto i think his [ __ ] is like i've
no i think his house is straight up call
like he calls it like the embassy
because yeah
and i know that because i reflect on the
dumbest observation when we saw his
house and we were like talking about it
here
i think that's what i said i'm like this
still looks like a government building
he kind of named it after that stupid
but he built it though right yeah i
think that way okay
yeah so i mean you already have an
embassy as a home yeah
but i'm trying to get him to that 10
billion yeah no i think it's really cool
that after you fill out your direct
deposit when you work at starbucks and
you're like hey
is it possible to
you guys like i know we're in america
but i wanted to go to a canadian account
is that
is that possible why glad
drake uh he's going on tour soon i just
want to make sure he's got like some you
know pot money in his pocket so he could
gamble a little bit you know just make
sure he has fun
um yeah
aubry aubry yeah that's my boy aubry
yeah
i've been kind of you know looking after
him recently
yeah making it a sob story yeah yeah my
boy you know he's just going through it
he's an artist man like he he put out
this album it was like really deep you
know um he's just kind of talking about
like
the struggle of just you know his
relationships and stuff yeah
so you know i just i kind of took up
this job to make sure that i could look
after him and
just kind of changed his hair recently
pretty drastically so i'm thinking maybe
he's like going through something yeah
so i figured i said you know send him a
little extra cheddar yeah even when you
listen to his music he talks a lot about
you know substance use and stuff it's
like i don't condone it but
okay what was the
drake is a villain bit that we were
doing with the parkour guy
oh i was just saying well apparently
that whole [ __ ] was fake
no way yeah no really apparently like
that wow that dude just it was all a
scam
that's unfortunate because it's a
hilarious way you never told me that i
think we were talking about like drake
like hooking up with dude's girls and it
just prompts them to be really good at
parkour
[Laughter]
like that's how angry and like upset you
are you just become like a physical
[ __ ]
phenom like
defy all laws of your genetics like
you hear what happened to david no yeah
this girl cheated on him with drake and
now he's got a 12 foot vertical
he's a little bit too old someone do a
backflip 360 on playing ground yeah he
can do that now i saw him do it he's a
little bit too old to go to the league
but they're like studying him because
they're trying to replicate what's going
on in his legs and their own players